hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american fantasy drama movie called
powder
there is a pregnant woman who was
running for shelter because of the heavy
rain
not long after unfortunately she is
struck by lightning
she is immediately taken to the hospital
it turns out that the woman was dead but
her baby can be saved by the doctor
the incident makes the baby have to be
born prematurely after the operation the
doctor finds something wrong with the
baby the baby suffers from a genetic
disorder commonly known as albinism
which makes his skin very white and
cannot see the sun because his eyes are
very sensitive to light because of that
his father disowns him shortly after his
birth
later he is raised by his grandparents
18 years later his grandfather is found
dead of natural causes
therefore no one will take care of him
anymore
as the result the police come to check
the house they also contact jessie a
child services psychologist telling her
that they want to leave the child so she
can take care of him the locals inform
the police that the child has lived in
the basement and has never been to
school
he always works on the farm every day
never leaving his property once as they
meet him in the basement they are very
surprised because of his unusual looks
but jesse believes that he is a good boy
the boy says his name is jeremy on the
other hand jesse is confused because he
can speak fluently even though he never
goes to school she also sees a lot of
books in the basement and she wants to
test his intelligence
jeremy then asks her to name one of the
pages in the book and he will mention
its full contents
obviously he can mention it perfectly
because he has incredible intellect and
he has learned everything from his books
all the time
jesse decides to take him to a boy's
home because he's now a ward of the
state there everyone looks at him
strangely some even bully him
however he is able to amaze them all
with his ability his brain possesses a
powerful electromagnetic charge which
causes electrical objects to function
abnormally when he is around them
particularly when he becomes emotional
soon jesse gives him a pair of eye
contact so he can see in daylight she
also enrolls him in a high school the
first lesson is physics where he meets
donald as the teacher of the class
during a practical session on
electricity the teacher finds out that
jeremy has supernatural powers causing
him to be struck by lightning
donald immediately breaks the practical
equipment with a chair
as the result jeremy is taken to the
hospital straight away luckily the
doctor says that he is fine when he
returns to his home a professor informs
him that he has the highest iq in
history from the previous test
while his abilities mark him as special
they also make him an outcast
on a hunting trip with his schoolmates
he is threatened with a gun by john an
aggressive student who views him as a
freak
before john can fire a gun goes off in
the distance
everyone rushes to the place and sees
that a sheriff's deputy named harley has
shot a doe
anguished by the animal's death jeremy
touches both the deer and harley at the
same time
consequently he admits that jeremy had
actually caused him to feel the pain and
fear of the dying deer because of the
experience he removes all of his guns
from his house although his senior
sheriff doug allows him to remain as a
sheriff's deputy without a sidearm
knowing jeremy's superpower sheriff doug
enlists jeremy to help speak to his
dying wife through telepathy through
jeremy the sheriff learns that his wife
clings on to life because she doesn't
want to die while not wearing her
wedding ring and without him reconciling
with his estranged son steven
she tells him that steven already found
the ring and that it has been sitting in
a silver box on her nightstand the
entire time
at the end the sheriff places the ring
on his wife's finger and reconciles with
stephen letting his wife die peacefully
later jeremy falls in love with his
classmate named lindsay it turns out
that she secretly has feelings for
jeremy he immediately touches her hand
to show his telepathic abilities he
wants to know her thoughts and vice
versa
from the telepathy he reveals that she
lacks confidence because she doesn't
think she is beautiful enough because of
that jeremy immediately praises her
beauty
suddenly lindsay's father comes and
forbids their relationship
at the right time jessie also comes and
tells him not to bother jeremy lindsay
and her father finally leave the place
causing jeremy to feel bad for their
action earlier
feeling sad he goes back to the juvenile
facility and packs away his belongings
planning to run away to his farm
while he is walking he is approached
again by john
he steals jeremy's hat and taunts him
he and the other boys humiliate jeremy
stripping him naked and taunting him his
powers begin to manifest by pulling at
their metal buttons and any piercings
eventually a large spherical
electromagnetic pulse erupts throwing
jeremy into a mud puddle and everyone
else to the ground
thus they find john's heart has stopped
jeremy immediately uses his electric
shock to revive him
after the incident he returns to the
farm where he grew up he then finds that
all of his possessions have been removed
shortly after he is joined by jesse
donald and doug who persuade him to come
with them to find a place where he will
not be feared and misunderstood
instead he chooses to run into a field
where a lightning bolt will strike him
because of that he disappears in a
blinding flash of light the electrical
jolt also hits jesse donald harley and
doug as they witness jeremy disappear
from the farm
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching